[Music]
are you going to meet a boy no okay
[Music]
excuse me
can you buy some booze for my friends
and I not interested please he'll oh
there's my girl
this never happened okay thanks again
for doing this ma'am
you guys want to party like rock stars
follow me let's go
the bar is open
do you think we don't know this chick
made much but it's all you cool basement
you're free to do whatever you walk down
here but nobody go upstairs welcome to
Maude's what loan ma how did she get our
numbers you know what the body
those earrings are beautiful Maggie you
got a sweet mama huh who are you with
just some kids from school you have a
boyfriend many dogs there's something
off about mom seriously she's honest and
her basements pretty much the best
drinking spot in town
we can't go home thanks for these
earrings what happened last night I
don't want to hang out at malls anymore
I want you to meet someone
nice to meet you Maggie we went to high
school together why is my son Ethan out
just like your daddy's spending time at
your house
that [ __ ] is crazy probably something
wrong with me how does it feel to be on
the outside
[Applause]
this is the most fun I've had in a long
time
[Music]
you